let's see if we could figure out what to
over 3 divided by 5 is equal to pause
this video and see if you can figure
this out well there's a couple of ways
that we can approach it we can first do
it in a conceptual way think about it
visually and to do that let me represent
2/3 so let's say that this that what I'm
drawing right over here is a hole this
is a square and it represents a hole and
now I could divide into 3 equal sections
and I'm going to try to hand draw that
so this is that looks pretty good
three equal sections here each is a
third and we have two thirds so we are
really representing all of this stuff
right over here that is two of my thirds
now I want to divide those two thirds by
five
well the way I could do this is I could
divide it into five equal sections but
if I'm doing it I might as well just
divide everything all the thirds into
five equal sections so let me do that so
one two three and then four and five
equal sections
so what is one of those five equal
sections of my original 2/3 well this
right over here is one of those five
equal sections of my original 2/3 notice
I could draw that I could draw another
one here another one here another one
there and another one there and I would
have five equal sections that make up
those two thirds but what does just one
of them represent and if we figure out
what this represents of the hole then we
know what two thirds divided by five is
well when I took my thirds and I divided
them into five equal sections I
essentially constructed 15 how do I know
that well I had one to three thirds and
then I divided it into one two three
four five sections so each of these
squares right over here is a fifteenth
you have three times five and you could
count them if you like and what we have
called off in red is two of these 15 we
have one fifteenth right over here and
then to 15th right over there
so this is going to be equal to two over
15 now another way that you could think
about it and over time this is the way
you will approach it but it's nice to
think about it conceptually is when you
divide by any number it's the same thing
as multiplying by the reciprocal so five
five is the same thing as five holes or
five over one and so 2/3 divided by five
is the same thing as 2/3 times the
reciprocal of five or the reciprocal of
5 over one which is you just swap the
numerator in the denominator which is 1
over 5 and so another way of thinking
about this is this is 1/5 of 2/3 which
is once again will be this section right
over here and the way you could compute
this conceptually you see that this is
215
but you could also say well I can just
multiply it when I multiply fractions I
can just multiply the numerators 2 times
1 is 2 let me do that same red color 2
times 1 is 2 and then I can multiply the
denominators 3 times 5 is 15 and
hopefully what we just drew out may
helps make sense of why we can why
dividing by something is the same thing
as multiplying by the reciprocal and
then when you multiply fractions it's
the same thing as multiplying the
numerators to get our new numerator and
then multiplying the denominators to get
our new denominator